neuf mois après sa création il vient
inaugure son usine à flins dans le nord
des yvelines en partenariat avec renault
et plug power cette usine représente la
première chaîne d'assemblage de piles à
combustible en france c'est pile
alimenteront les futurs véhicules
renault rno à l'évident vous amène le
savoir-faire sur le véhicule utilitaire
et placards us est le leader mondial de
l'hydrogène nous sommes quand même
toujours focalisés sur les bonnes
solutions pour nos clients est ce que
c'est les électriques batteries ou
est-ce que c'est maintenant hydrogène
donc nous sommes quand même pionniers à
avoir les meilleures solutions pour nos
clients mardi 15 mars renault yvias et
plug power ont révélé les trois
véhicules prototypes qui disposeront du
système de pile à combustible cette
nouvelle technologie permettra notamment
aux véhicules électriques d'avoir plus
d'autonomie un des intérêts pour le
client du type de véhicule utilitaire
c'est l'autonomie et la durabilité avec
l' architecture dual power on a en fait
un véhicule hybride qui utilisent le
carburant hydrogène soit pour créer
l'électricité qui propulse le véhicule
soit pour recharger la batterie pour
augmenter l'autonomie du véhicule dans
tous les cas avec cette architecture
dual power on va on va garantir une
autonomie l usage de l'ordre de 400 à
450 km sur les véhicules utilitaires
légers soit la pile recharge la batterie
dans une situation
tranquille on va dire et quand vous avez
besoin de toute la puissance la pile et
la batterie alimente le moteur
électrique il via a pour objectif de
proposer mille système de pile à
combustion en un an